today when I'm reading stuff and I know
Ben is the same way like if I even hear
somebody say the word like anti-racism
I'm probably ignoring every other thing
you have to say uh if you utter the word
like Colonial anything I'm probably
going to say you probably don't have
anything uh good to say um yeah a lot of
it is just taken way too far but you
know what I will blame on some of this
is I will blame conservatives for some
of this because I think one issue that
happens and I think Ben might even agree
with me here too is I think there
there's two huge problems that have
happened in the United States I think
broadly speaking is that one we become
more different than we ever have been
and two we become more similar than we
ever have been and when I say this what
I mean is that like we're splitting off
into these groups and then these groups
are enforcing this insane homogeneity
between these two separate groups and I
think one of these schisms has been
conservatives reluctancy to participate
in things related to higher uh education
uh so for a long time conservatives are
saying like oh you know the educational
institutions are against us you know
Russ lmb talks about how evil the
colleges are and blah blah blah and then
what happens is is conservatives are
less and less willing to engage in them
so then you get this scenario or this
environment where everybody that's
engaged in uh Academia on the
administrative side are are [__]
insane they're they like even more so to
and I also want to draw a distinction
here between like the the administrators
and the faculty because often times when
you're reading story after story after
Story of like all of these insane admins
that are pushing further and further
left usually The Faculty is fighting
against it a lot of the tenure
professors a lot of people in their
departments are saying like hold on well
we actually don't agree with this but I
feel like because conservatives for so
long have demonized these institutions
rather than like critically evaluated
them uh and tried to like have like
honest critique and engagement that
they've just like completely broken off
and when you only have a bunch of
lefties or righties together all they'll
do is they Veer off like even more into
their insane directions uh I feel like
that's a big problem that we run into in
the country to where conservatives have
totally broken off some conversations
broken away from where they won't
participate in them anymore and then the
people that you have left just run as as
far to the left as possible certainly
when you look at certain institutions I
think that one of the things that people
on both sides of the aisle are
constantly looking at is has the
institution suffered such capture that
there is just no capacity to fix it and
when you talk about the universities I'm
not going to blame conservatives for the
failure of the universities because they
haven't been present in major positions
at universities since effectively the
late 1960s you can go read Shelby
Steel's work on this where he talks
about how you know he used to be he's
now a conservative black person he was a
liberal black person at the time he was
actually quite a radical black activist
at the time in the 60s and he he talks
about walking into the office of liberal
administrators who were largely on his
side with regard to civil rights and
being a radical him claiming that the
systems of the University were
inherently broken were inherently wrong
unfixable and he talks about this very
it's a very evocative episode where he's
talking about how he's smoking and as
he's smoking the ash is growing more and
more and the ash falls down on this very
expensive carpet and the president of
the University who's listening to him
rant and Rave he's he's Shelby steel
says I thought he was going to say
something about this I mean I was
wrecking like a$1 thousand carpet in his
office being a jackass and instead I
could see him will inside I could see
him collapse he didn't have the
institutional credibility or the intelle
or or sort of the spiritual strength to
just say listen I agree with you on some
of these things but you're acting like a
jackass and what you see in the late
1960s and early 1970s is in fact the
collapse of these institutions to the
point where by the time I was going to
college there was this radical
disproportion between conservatives and
liberals and the problem is that when it
comes to system like the universities
basically have to separate the
universities off into two separate
categories one is stem where the
universities are still pretty damn good
American universities when it comes to
stem are still leading universities in
the world Harvard's main Creations these
days are coming from actual hard science
field then you have the liberal arts
field in which you basically have a
self-perpetuating elite because that's
actually how dissertations work if you
have somebody who's very far to the left
and you decide that you're going to
write a dissertation on the history of
American gun rights the chances that
that is going to be approved by your
dissertation adviser are much lower than
if you happen to write something that
tends to agree with the political
positions of your dissertation adviser
now listen I think there are open and
tolerant professors even in the liberal
arts of these universities I went to
these universities right I went to UCLA
I went to Harvard Law School when I was
at Harvard Law School one of my favorite
professors was lonni guier Lon guier
they tried to appoint her I believe
Secretary of Labor under Clinton and she
was too liberal and she got rejected so
she was like a full-on communist by the
time I went there she was great we had
debates every day it was wonderful she
used to write me recommendations for my
my legal jobs after we left Randle
Kennedy I don't agree with him very much
Rand Kenn was terrific Professor there
are some professors who are like this
unfortunately there tends to be in these
Echo Chambers more and more ideological
Conformity that is rigorously enforced
and it is by left on left so for example
when I was at Harvard Law School the
president of the University was another
president who ended up being outed Larry
Summers Larry Summers had been the
Secretary of Treasury under Bill Clinton
and he made the critical error of
suggesting that perhaps the dir of women
in hard Sciences in prestigious
positions was due to possibly two
factors that people were refusing to
talk about one was was the possibility
that women actually didn't want to be in
hard Sciences at nearly the rates that
men do which happens to be true uh and
two was the distribution of stem IQ
right which is something that you
certainly were not allowed to talk about
the idea that that the men's bell curve
when it comes to IQ particularly on stem
subjects tends to be shallower than the
women's bell curves when you get to the
very end of the bell curve what you tend
to see is a lot of really dumb guys and
a lot of really smart guys and so when
you're talking about the top
universities maybe that has something to
do with the disproportion and he's
trying to explain that to say that our
systems are not discriminating if we end
up more men than women maybe more men
are applying and more men are qualified
that's that's quite he was outed for
that by a leftwing faculty and and you
know General Alum Network at at Harvard
University so there's a lot to blame
conservatives for for surrendering the
playing field I totally agree that
conservatives should not have
surrendered the playing field in some
institutions colleges were surrendered a
lot earlier than 20 years ago they were
surrendered in the late 1960s early
1970s yeah so I think that um a couple
things so uh one of the big issues that
I have with kind of like this uh I don't
know if we call it era of trumpism or
populism is this total disregard for
institutions and this disconnect from
participation in the system so it's one
of the big things that I F with
progressives about who who cares because
they're all 20 years old they don't vote
anyway um but it's another thing that I
notice with a lot of people that are uh
Trump voters Trump fans or whatever is
this idea where we say this institution
is uh irrevocably destroyed it it's
irredeemable it can't be saved it can't
nothing that we do can can fix it um and
I think that what that leads people to
doing is one they disconnect further and
then two there's a general hopelessness
when it comes to how Society is like ran
or structured such that you fall into
that populous brain rot of the only
person that can save me is Donald Trump
I can't trust literally anything and I
think that when you start driving people
into that direction all it does is it
further amplifies all the problems that
you're complaining about so that's one
of the reasons why when we talk about
like conservative participation I want
there to be more conservatives that are
trying to participate in Academia but I
feel like the leading thought or the
leading speaking out against it is
basically saying it's a waste of time
it's completely lost so I think that the
alternative to that is that you are
seeing on the right a growth of for
example alternative universities the
worst thing no I I I don't think so at
all I think competition is a great way
of incentivizing some change on on
behalf of universities that may have
forgotten that there's an entire another
side of the aisle in the United States
meaning no no shot I don't believe even
I don't think even you think that so
first of all first of all let me make
clear I think the entire educational
system at the upper levels if you're not
in stem is a complete scam I think it's
a complete waste of money I think it's a
complete waste of time and I think that
it's all all it is is a formalized very
expensive sorting mechanism for people
of IQ that's all it is people take an
SAT you go to a good school you take
four years of [__] I know I did at
UCLA and then we analyze based on your
degree where you should go to law school
I could have gone directly from high
school to law school with maybe one year
of training and then done one year of
law school and been done okay the
reality is that this is a giant scam and
this again is a bipartisan problem but
it's just a generalized problem the we
we have and you want to talk about
things that hurt the lower classes in
the United States the bleeding of
degrees up is so wild and crazy there's
so many jobs in the United States that
should not require a college degree that
we now require a college degree to do
because there was this weird idea that
came over Americans where they mistook
correlation for causation they would say
oh look people who go to college are
making more money than people who don't
go to college therefore everyone should
go to college well maybe the reason is
because people who are going to college
were better qualified for particular
jobs because on average not all the time
but on average a lot of those people
were smarter and making more money
because of that and so all you've done
is youve now created these additional
layers of stratification so a person who
used to be able to get a job with a
college degree now has to have a postdoc
degree in order to go get that degree a
person who used to be able to just
graduate high school now it's the facto
you got to go to jco and then you got to
go to college or nobody's even going to
look at your resume it's really really
terrible for people who can't afford all
of that it's led to this massive
increase in educational cost that is
inexplicable other than this particular
sort of bleed up and by the way Federal
subsidies for higher education again one
of my problems with Federal subsidies
for higher education I'd love for
everyone to be able to go to college if
qualified to do so and if it is
productive but one of the things I did
when I went to law school is I took
loans because I B Bank said I was going
to get my money back if I got a law
degree from Harvard but you know when
you're not going to get your money back
if you're a bank you're not going to
lend to some dude who wants to major in
you know art Theory because is that a
good bet there's no collateral right if
I give a loan for a house I can go
repossess the house how do I repossess
your garbage college degree from UCLA
there's no way to do that so you know
one one of my so yeah this is a broader
conversation about education in general
I think the educational system is
cruising for a bruising and I think all
that's necessary for it to completely
collapse on the non- stem side where you
actually learn things is for people who
employ to Simply say give me your SAT
score and I will hire you for an
apprenticeship directly out of high
school that it would cut out so much of
the middleman but as far as the general
point that you're making about
institutions I I may disagree on the
education and how far it's gone in
general I agree with you so it's in in
general I agree and I get to use my my
favorite longest word in the English
language here I I would consider myself
in many cases an anti-is establishment
tanist nice right you see I like to drop
that that's because if you're an
establishmentarian that means you like
establishment anti can you say that word
that's the one we all learned growing up
anti- disestablishmentarianism long
word but and then some K Group say what
about super Calif fragile and then you
what about num ultra microscopic or the
science terms or what about the 7,000
letter thing that's from part of uh
biochem I got my education the Soviet
Union so we just did math didn't Lear
any of this that's why you're a useful
person Soviet Union math was that 1 plus
one how to make that equal three we know
long words and he streams on the
internet and I talk so anyway but the
the point is that I don't disagree that
there is a general populist tendency on
all sides of the aisle to look at the
institutions and then throw them
overboard I think that some of that is
earned by people who are in positions of
power at institutions who have
completely undermine the faith and
credibility of those institutions I
think you have to examine institution by
institutions which ones are salvageable
and which ones are not so I'm not a a
full anti- disestablishmentarianism I'd
be partially in that camp there are
certain institutions like higher
education in the liberal arts that I
think we may be better off without and
then there are certain institutions like
say participation in American government
where when people talk about we need a
revolution like no we don't that's not a
thing we need an evolution we need
change we need we can use the system and
and you know but I think you have to
estab you have to look at it industry by
industry you know institution by
institution on that position on
institutions do you think Biden or Trump
would side would you more uh as far as
the institutions yeah I think the
institutions in the United States at the
governmental level are robust I think
the social institutions are fair yeah
but I'm just curious on your general
view of institutions do you think Biden
or Trump would side would you more on
how you view them um I mean I think that
in rhetoric Biden would and then I think
that he would tear out the face of the
institution and wear it around like a
masc like cannibal Lector I mean that's
resisted some people's calls to like
pack the court and uh yes because I
think that his use of executive power
was greater than that of Donald Trump
the power that he had he used to Greater
effect than Donald Trump Donald Trump
again thrashed up against the sides of
the box but could not get out of it okay
um for just real quick because on the
that that answer went a lot further than
the initial question but yeah just on
the real quick thing the reason why I
again my main problem that I feel like
we have today in society is people are
getting into their own bubbles the idea
of having like conservative schools and
liberal School seems like the saddest
thing in the world to me like I would
want conservatives and liberals going to
school together because I think these
people need to interact with each other
more if for no other reason then to say
that the other person is not like an
actual monstrous horrible entity that
wants to destroy the country listen I
think a classically liberal idea for
many schools would not be a bad thing I
think would be a good thing I just
wonder if that's salvageable and if it's
not salvageable then the answer to that
is to actually create alternative in I
feel like the biggest issue that we have
is people are they sort into these
different like Phantom worlds to where
even if you live in the same city there
are totally different worlds that exist
between liberals and conservatives and I
feel like one of the big barriers to
people understanding the other side
sometimes is just a little bit of
information or a little bit of like
firsthand experience um when I so in
terms of information I'm sure you saw um
I don't I don't know if this is a
full-on study but they were talking
about how some huge percentage of
students would change their mind on from
The River To The Sea when you told them
what from the river to se what the river
was and what the sea was yeah uh or when
you said like yeah what does a one state
solution mean a lot of them like such
that the numbers went from like 70% to
like 30% in terms of like support um
would fall and it wasn't because you
were doing a radical redefining their
whole ideology you just giving them a
little bit more information um and then
something that I've seen on a firsthand
level is when I go and speak or do
debates at University sometimes I'm in
very very very conservative areas some
of my fans are are trans having like a
trans person show up and talk to
conservatives for a little bit uh not
like in a speech but just like in a in
like a bar or a setting like a lot of
them walk away they like oh not every
trans person is like this insane lunatic
from Twitter that is [__] an actual
crazy person and then for some of my
fans when they hang out with
conservatives like oh these guys are
actually pretty friendly I thought they
would have all been homophobic racist
transphobic and evil but they're not
they're just like normal people I feel
like we need more of that I totally
agree with that certainly yeah and I
feel like on our social media platforms
on our algorithms and our schools I feel
like we're sorting harder and harder and
harder and any type of rhetoric that
encourages the Sorting is really bad and
damaging we need to like continue to mix
up and there's other things I want to
talk about is opening his mouth Destiny
the uniter wow all right bid as we not
like
Trump